I want to try today to tackle one of the
most commonly issued complaints about
Singapore mathematics
namely why are there so many word
problems and you may be a student who is
getting assigned a bunch of word
problems and are unhappy with how
difficult they are you may be a teacher
looking at the curriculum and saying do
I really have to do all these word
problems with my student you may be a
parent I was just frustrated by a child
coming home and not knowing what to do
with a word problem or even really how
to help them right and I think probably
if we at least as adults think back to
our own education where problems were
some of the most difficult and
frustrating things in our own
mathematics education so I want to try
to say well why in this math curriculum
that we think is really valuable why is
so much of it centered around the idea
of word problems um and I think to a
certain extent I sympathize with all of
us who really do struggle with word
problems because I think they are the
most challenging part of the elementary
mathematics curriculum right and let's
just explore a little bit why they're so
challenging and this list is not going
to be unfamiliar to most of you
you guys could probably come up with a
better list than I can here even but I
think there's a number of things that
make weird problems very very difficult
right first you know it's difficult to
know even where to start right how many
of us when we Rea read a word problem
get the end to be like okay I read all
those words but but where do I start
actually doing some of the math here
right I don't know where to start right
second this idea of the textbook writers
always throwing in the extra facts that
you don't really need I've got to
eliminate these extraneous information
why do they do that why did they try to
trick us three right just the idea of
trying to figure out the correct
equation of operation or operation right
and a lot of times students will you
know see two numbers and the problem and
kind of just say should we add them
subtract them right and and just kind of
guessing an equation or an operation or
it's very difficult to go from a word
problem to an equation right it's this
idea of progressing from the concrete to
the abstract here right fourthly I think
determining what the problem is even
asking for right what do they want me to
actually do here what do all these words
really mean
five right checking if your answer makes
some sense
I you get to answer you're like well I
don't know if that's right or wrong but
I got this number is this right and you
kind of put it in the blank and and and
move on I think that you know that's
difficult well and lastly maybe this
should have been first right just the
idea that word problems require this
reading this comprehension this
translation from one language to another
from the language of words from the
language this vocal language to the
language of mathematics right and I
think you know it's no wonder that with
a word problem there's so much sources
of frustration right these are not
difficult things to do here right and
and they're very you know they can be
kind of paralyzing in a way that other
problems can't right I could read the a
word problem and just kind of sit there
after I read it and just say I don't
know where to go from here and and yet
right in the midst of why these things
are frustrated I want you to take one
more look at this list right and these
are exactly the kind of virtues and the
things we want to see in our students
these are the kind of thoughtfulness
these are the kind of thinking that we
want them to be able to develop when
they encounter not just a math problem
but any kind of a problem in their
everyday life right any and this this
could be you know from from kind of a
relational conversational problem a
physical problem a mental problem right
any one of these problems right these
are the things they're gonna struggle
with these are the things we all
struggle with right we don't know where
to start we don't know what matters and
what doesn't matter right we don't know
whether we need to put more there or
less there or what how we might model
the situation with an operation right
we don't even know sometimes and we
encounter a problem what it's asking for
right we always need to read comprehend
and translate right and and and you know
figuring out whether or not my answer
that I arrived at is gonna work these
are the skills here the life virtues
that we want our students to develop
right and so why so many word problems
in Singapore math I think what happened
what's happened is the writers of the
curriculum have realized why
math is valuable right math is valuable
not just because it allows us to kind of
manipulate some symbols and get some
answers here right math is valuable
because it teaches us a way of thinking
that allows us to engage problems in a
dynamic fashion right and the best way
to work with to work with students to
develop that kind of thinking is to
engage with them in word problems now
this isn't easy right and so what sink
where math also does is try to provide
the tools to deal with this right you
should really watch a few of the videos
about bar modeling to get a sense of
where or how Singapore Math equips
teachers students parents to be able to
have the conversations about word
problems with their students right but
if we can take advantage of those tools
and really work with work to delve
deeply into the word problems we're
gonna be developing these kind of skills
and students right so if you're a
student starting the word problems
I could exhort you to persevere if
you're a parent we got a packets at home
don't do the work of translating the
word problem into an equation for your
kid work with your kid to engage with
all these difficulties right ask them
these kind of questions where can you
start help them to write learn something
about bar modeling to be able to help
them write if you're a teacher looking
through your curriculum and you see all
those word problems don't shy away from
them all right engage deeper in them
because they're going to be the things
that are really gonna produce lasting
effects in our students
you